hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer minecraft 1.7 neuerungen
vorstellungen von mir und zwar habe ich
mir bei dieser vorstellung sehr sehr
sehr sehr viel mühe gegeben da es sehr
lange gedauert hat die ganzen infos
zusammen zu suchen
die ganzen zehn zusammenzuschneiden
beziehungsweise erst mal zusammen zu
karten bzw zusammen aufzunehmen und
alles mögliche allgemeinen vorzubereiten
weil auch so viele neue sachen dazu
gekommen sind ich habe noch nie so ein
großes umfangreiches und auch geiles
update erlebt deswegen möchte ich das
für euch auf jeden fall sogar wie
möglich gestaltet haben und ich hoffe
ich habe das hingekriegt deswegen wenns
euch auf jeden fall gefällt würde ich
mich sehr sehr tolle beiden daumen wo
freuen dass es einfach nur ein klick und
wenn es euch gefällt ich hab mir echt
locker sechs sieben stunden mit arbeit
gemacht und ungelogen jetzt und das
würde ich auf jeden fall sehr sehr geil
finden wir nicht einfach den daumen hoch
geben würde das wird mir zeigen dass wir
sowas feiert und ich habe übrigens auch
immer mal in dem video oben links von
kleinen stern eingefügt und zwar immer
wenn ihr diesen stern seht könnt ihr
einfach zu dieser sache in die
kommentare schreiben
was ihr davon haltet von dieser änderung
weil das grundlegende änderungen sind
und da würd mich einfach eure meinung
events diskutieren bzw
ich möchte damit euch darüber
diskutieren und ich würde eure meinung
auf jeden fall dazu sehr interessieren
deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen viel spaß
beim video und viel spaß
fangen wir mit der welt generierung an
es wurde ein neuer welt hinzugefügt und
zwar der zerklüftete welt typ welcher
große biome mit 200 meter hohen bergen
und tiefe schluchten bis zur 0 höhe mit
flüssen hinzufügt und in den flussbetten
liegt teilweise sogar keystone
allerdings benötigt diese dieser welt
einen guten pc und das ist eigentlich
auch nur zum spaß gedacht machen wir
weiter mit den neuen biologen die
hinzugefügt wurden und zwar die tiefsee
beispielsweise ist zehn blöcke tiefer
als ein normaler ozean und die maximale
tiefe ist im geringen 30er bereich von y
die eiszapfen tundra beinhaltet riesige
türme aus packeis und es sieht so
ähnlich aus wie umgedrehte eiszapfen die
sonnenblumen ebenes einfach ganz normale
ebene nur mit sonnenblumen halt der
blumenwelt es eine neue variante des
waldes mit weniger bäumen aber dafür
verschiedene neuen arten von blumen zu
den ich nachher noch kommen werde
ja dann gibt es noch den birkenwald und
was der hat sagt der name glaube ich
selbst schon dieser wann ist ebenfalls
ein neues bio welches ak 10 beim aus
tropenholz beinhaltet werde sehr sehr
häufig spawnen weil sie auch wildtiere
sind und es kann auch npc dörfer
enthalten dann gibt es auch noch zwei
neue tafelberg biom und zwar mesa und
bryce berichtigt mich wenn ich das
irgendwie falsch ausgesprochen habe
jedenfalls beinhaltet mesa tote büsche
und verschiedenfarbig gebrannten lehmann
der oberfläche es beinhaltet roten sand
und es gibt dort außerdem keinen regen
sowie in der wüste bei preis ist es
einfach so dass es ähnlich wie eiszapfen
tundra ist aber mit bergen aus leben
anstatt packeis kommen wir nun zur
allgemeinen riesentanker dort treten
große eichen mit 2 x 2 block dicken
stämmen auf es enthält pop soul das ist
ein neuer blog zu dem ich auch gleich
noch kommen dass es nicht eine andere
variante der erde
es enthält außerdem erde auf der kein
gras wachsen kann formationen aus dem
osten pflasterstein büsche pilze und
fahne spawn dort außerdem und was fahne
sind sind einfach so braune wüsten
grasbüschel teile und wie in der wüste
und dem tafelberg regnet es dort nicht
die riesen schichten tigers ein
untergeordnetes billionen von der riesen
tiger und was ist das gleiche wie ein
riesenteil gang nur mit fichten wollen
dann gibt es außerdem noch den dichten
wald wo riesige pilze natürlich
vorkommen und große fichten wollen mit 2
x 2 block dicken stämmen und normale
birken und eichen generiert werden
monster können dort übrigens auch
tagsüber spawn aufgrund des dichten
blätterdach ist die kalte tiger ist
außerdem ein neues bio welches quasi der
normalen tiger entspricht allerdings mit
schnee bedeckt das letzte video das
hinzugefügt wurde ist das extreme hill 2
und plus bonus noch fichten dazu kommen
dann allgemein alles schöner aussieht
außerdem gibt es nun neue technische
biom und varianten zbm biome sind
deutlich seltener als alle anderen bio
varianten das m steht hinter einem baum
zum beispiel für [ __ ] beispielsweise
savanne emsa wann hochebene m tafelberg
hochebene im dschungel im dichter wald
im tiger extreme hitze und extreme sm
haben bergige landschaften als ihre
gegensätze in den normalen biom die
wüste m enthält wasserquellen im
gegensatz zu normalen wüste und der
birkenwald m hat höhere birken als das
normale birken ihm außerdem trennt
strand biome nun land von meer und
flüssen dabei gibt es beispielsweise den
steinstrand der besteht hauptsächlich
aus stein
tritt oft zwischen extreme hält bio
mundwasser auf und den kalten strand
bestehend aus sand und einer
schneeschicht der entsteht oft dem
kalten bio kommen wir nun zu den
verbesserungen und änderungen an bio-
und zwar gibt es größere
höhenunterschiede und zwar berge bis y
100 und technische werke sind
beispielsweise allgemein höher als die
normalen berg biome berge bis höhe y 150
können beispielsweise extreme hills biom
oberhalb der höri psion 95 schnee
enthalten und es können auch große stein
erd- und kiesflächen enthalten seien
außerdem wurden auch im dschungel einige
dinge hinzugefügt bzw verändert und zwar
können dort mehr lohn nur noch normal
vorkommt und auch normal wachsen und sie
sind nicht nur noch aus thun erhalt war
des weiteren kommenden dschungel bio mit
deutlich seltener als in den vorherigen
versionen vor und die bäume haben dort
nun auch erste und am dschungel land
gibt es nur noch weniger laub das stellt
zb einen guten übergang zum richtigen
dschungel er das gras im sumpf ist nun
grüner und hat außerdem einen anderen
farbton welcher temperatur abhängig ist
zu der temperatur komme ich übrigens
gleich noch also bleibt ruhig noch ein
bisschen daran blue kleiner zuschauer
die ozeane sind allgemeinen kleiner und
haben nur noch bis am grund dazu
ergänzen kann man eigentlich auch
vielleicht sagen dass kies strände
allgemein häufiger vorkommen der brunnen
npc dörfer in den wüsten wird jetzt aus
pflastersteinen und der grund aus kies
gepflastert des weiteren können nun
komplett unterschiedliche die ohne nicht
mehr nebeneinander auftreten da es nun
temperaturabhängig ist zb kann nicht ein
eiszapfen tundra neben einer wüste vor
kam aber schon viel eher eine savanne
neben einer wüste da dies nun möglich
ist aufgrund der temperatur da jedes
biom eine unterschiedliche temperatur
hat zb biome unter der temperatur 015
haben schnee anstatt regen und über 1,15
haben zum beispiel gar kein regen es
werden nun partikel beim aufschlag eines
tiefen preis erzeugt und zwar macht
diese höhe einen unterschied zu dieser
höhe welche wiederum einen unterschied
zu dieser höhe macht es gibt nur ein
ende der welt in minecraft und zwar der
koordinate iks oder y gleich 30
millionen erscheint eine unsichtbare
wand wenn man sich allerdings darüber
hinaus porte beziehungsweise durch
irgendein command ist man in einem blog
drin und kann sich nicht mehr bewegen
ist dementsprechend gefangen es gibt
außerdem immens viele änderungen bei den
fischen und zwar kann man nur noch
andere dinge als nur fische fangen es
gibt nun nämlich drei verschiedenen
gruppen die man durch anderen erhalten
kann und zwar erstens schätze welche
beispielsweise verzauberte angeln bögen
bücher namenschilder haken wehres und
sättel darstellen können die zweite
gruppe sind die sogenannten
mödl dinge und zwar zb beschädigte an
den glasflaschen verortet das fleisch
fäden leder schüsseln stöcke und
beschädigte schuhe
die dritte gruppe sind die altbewährten
fische wo allerdings neue fische dazu
gekommen sind wie beispielsweise die
kugelfische wenn man diese ist bekommt
man einerseits einen neuen hunger balken
andererseits erhält man allerdings auch
den trank effekt vergiftung 44 60
sekunden und hunger 3 und übelkeit 2 für
jeweils 15 sekunden
außerdem wird der kugelfisch benötigt um
den neuen unterwasser atmungs trank zu
brauen zu dem ich aber gleich auch noch
mal kommen werde ein anderer neuen
zugefügt der fisch ist der clown fisch
oder halt nemo dieser hält außerdem auch
einen hunger balken und er wird benötigt
um ozelot neuerdings zu zähmen außerdem
kommt nun auch der lachs hinzu dieser
hält so einen hunger balken und gebraten
drei hunger balken des weiteren wurden
auch verzauberungen für angeln
hinzugefügt wie zum beispiel glück des
meeres das senkt die chance dass man
diesen ganzen unnötigen trödel angelt
oder auch verlockungen das verringert
nämlich die zeit bis ein nächster fisch
anbeißt es dreht nun außerdem blasen in
richtung haken auf welche so partikel
effekte beim fischen darstellen sollen
kurz bevor ein fisch anbeißen beim
bilderrahmen ist nun so dass man mit
einem klick auf den bilderrahmen das
enthaltene item bekommt unter einem
zweiten klick den rahmen die farbe des
zuckerrohrs hängt davon ab in welchem
biomass wächst und wenn man einen
creeper außerdem neuerdings anzündet
explodiert er direkt die feuerzeug
zutaten anordnung im crafting tables
mittlerweile vollkommen egal und die
karten nutzen und den kompletten block
beim dranhängen aus und zeigen außerdem
die farbe von gefärbter wolle und
lehmann man kann nun den toten bush
außerdem aufleben harten leben und erde
setzen und der neue unter wasser atmungs
trank erlaubt einem von drei minuten
unter wasser atmen zu können
und den braucht man halt wie vorhin
schon gesagt mit dem kugelfisch das
never portal kann an einem beliebigen
blog mittlerweile angezündet werden und
man kann andere formen bis 23 mal 23
verwenden
es muss allerdings rechteckig sein und
mindestens bei der höhe 4 x 5 anfang
wenn das portal außerdem netter groß
genug ist können auch gas sei dadurch in
die normale welt gelangen
hexen können nun den trank der unter
wasser atmen ist rob fallen lassen und
sind jetzt auch normale mops die bei
einem licht level unter sieben paaren
ähnlich oft wie another man's braucht
bei einem gewitter wird nun das
allgemeine licht dunkler die wolken
werden deutlich dunkler und der himmel
wird allgemein schwarz die texturen auf
oberen unterseite von holzbrettern
unterscheiden sich neuerdings dazu kann
man außerdem unter wasser nicht mehr die
wasseroberfläche sehen und die boote
steuertasten wo
vertauscht und das sprinten vielleicht
die geschwindigkeitssteigerung ist
außerdem boten möglich machen wir nun
weiter mit den neuen blöcken die
hinzugefügt wurden und zwar das pop soul
das portal ist auf deutsch übersetzt so
was wie blei fährt oder grau erde das
potts bekommt außerdem nur der riesen
tiger vor ist nur mit behutsamkeit
verzauberung erhalt bar und auf ihn kann
kein gras wachsen dann gibt es außer dem
schirm akazien bäume und diese kommen
nur in savannen vor das pack als kann
nicht schmelzen und die textur ist
außerdem trüber als die des normalen
eises bei den blumen und pflanzen hat
sich einiges getan denn es kommen
beispielsweise sonnenblumen pfingstrosen
trip mit den farben rot orange weiß und
rosa flieder mohn blaue euch den lauch
margerite eine noch nicht definierte
blumen und einen rosenstrauch hinzu es
gibt außerdem neue silberfisch deinen
allen vier verschiedenen steinarten der
rote sand kommt nur ein tafelbergen vor
und kann wie normaler sand verwendet
werden um beispielsweise glas oder tnt
herzustellen kommen wir nun zu dem
gefärbten glas und zwar kann man
gelassen alle 16 farben färben dafür
muss man einfach einen farbstoff in die
mitte einer werkbank tun und 8 lars
blöcke drum oben lägen dann bekommt man
nämlich acht gefärbte glas blöcke diese
gefärbten glasglocke kann man mit dem
gleichen rezept wie damals zu gefärbten
glasscheiben machen und außerdem
beeinflussen die angrenzenden blöcke die
glas farbe geringfügig es gibt außerdem
neue holzarten bretter arten brett
stufen treppen setzlinge und laub arten
für die neuen aktien und schwarz eichen
die setzlinge für die schwarzen müssen
allerdings in einem 2 x 2 feld platziert
werden wie zb die tropen bäume dann gibt
es auch noch diverse andere infos die
allerdings nicht so wichtig sind wie
beispielsweise änderungen am menü erfolg
und statistiken neue befehle wie
beispielsweise sap world sports umwelt
sport setzen oder tel rehov für
individuelle nachricht einstellungen sei
die zählweise der gewichteten
druckplatten wurde außerdem geändert
eine lore mit einem kommando blog ist
mittlerweile nur durch einen befehl zu
erhalten kann man allerdings
mittlerweile auch spannen lassen
es wurden änderungen am ressourcen paket
system hinzugefügt wie beispielsweise
ein neuer auswahlbildschirm und man kann
selbst neue sounds hinzufügen es gibt
außerdem jetzt server icons man muss er
fünf drücken zum aktualisieren der
server liste und ein komplett neuer
netzwerk b 418 also dieser minecraft
musiker typ da er kündigte außerdem neue
musik an die jetzt bald in zukunft
erscheinen wird
außerdem gibt es noch diverse neue
optionen wie beispielsweise individuelle
einstellung der sounds
grafikeinstellungen und die shader
option super secret settings und etliche
bug fix ist
das video war auf jeden fall sehr sehr
langen der macher das waren jetzt
bestimmt sechs stunden die ich an
information raussuchen karten schneiden
hochladen et cetera gebracht hat und das
war echt eine menge aber ich glaube ich
habe noch nie so viel arbeit für einen
video gegeben
ich würde mich echt freuen wenn ihr das
video mit einem daumen hoch bewerten
würde wenn es euch auf jeden fall
gefallen hat ihr diese arbeit honoriert
die ich mir dafür gegeben habe oder will
ich sagen schreib doch einfach mal zu
den sogenannten zu den vorhin schon
genannten sachen die ich mit zum stern
gekennzeichnet habe einfach mal in die
kommentare was ihr davon haltet und dann
will ich sagen gesehen beim nächsten mal
wieder unter